good morning believe nation today's
messages learn to connect over to you
Oprah Winfrey my life is fueled by my
being the being fuels to doing so I come
from a centered place I come from a
focused place I come from compassion
it's just my nature I come from a
willingness to understand and to be
understood and I come from wanting to to
to connect I mean the secret of that
show for 25 years is that people could
see themselves in me all over the world
they could see themselves in me and even
as I became more and more financially
successful which was a big surprise to
me I was like oh you mean you got more
than that 30,000 more than 30,000 by the
time I was 30 so so my but what I
realized is through the whole process
because I'm grounded in my own self that
although I could have more shoes my feet
stayed on the ground although I was
wearing better shoes he's cute today too
so I could keep my feet on the ground
even though I could get more shoes and I
could understand I could understand that
it really was because I was grounded
I've done the was doing and continue to
this day
to do the consciousness work I work at
staying awake and being awakened is just
another word for spirituality but
spirituality throws people off and they
think you being religion when I was
hiring people for my company for own
looking for presidents when people would
come in I'd say tell me what is your
spiritual practice and literally would
throw out people dog well the printer.i
well I'm not religious or that I said I
didn't ask you about your religion I
asked you what your spiritual practice
what do you do
to take care of yourself what do you do
to keep yourself centered what do you do
to the and uh you know one woman started
crying you know that's not the person
that's a sign so so to answer your
question everything is fueled that comes
from me really wanting to be a better
person on earth and this is what I know
to be true the reason why the show
worked is because I understood that that
audience my viewers the people who
watched us everyday and would come and
just like you all did get tickets and
they would come with their fight you all
just came across campus but that's good
too but people would come from all over
the world just to be there with their
aunts and their mothers and they come
with their cousins and there'd be a few
men and they're going what the hills or
saying well I went to Oprah with you I
went to Oprah at least give me clear for
three or four weeks I went to Oprah with
you I had such regard for that and I
just had a conversation with John Mackey
who runs Whole Foods
yeah and it's written this fabulous book
you should get it called conscious
capitalism and he was talking about how
the investment in the stakeholders the
people who you are serving that
connection between the people who you're
trying to serve and sell to is equally
as important as the people who you're
buying from equally as important as the
people who are you know supporting you
financially as your stockholders if you
are you know you know a public company
so I always understood that there really
was no difference between me and the
audience at times I might have had
better shoes but at the core the core of
what really matters that we are the same
and you know how I know that because all
of us are seeking the same thing you're
here at this fabulous school and we'll
go out into the world and each pursue
based upon what you believe
your talents are what your skills are
maybe your gifts are but you're seeking
the same thing everybody wants to
fulfill the highest truest expression of
yourself as a human being that's what
you're looking for the highest truest
expression of yourself as a human being
and because I understand that I
understand that if you're working in a
bakery and that's where you want to be
and that may be that may be what you've
always wanted to do is to bake pies for
people or bake cakes for people or to
offer your gift then then that's that's
for you and there's no difference
between you and me except that's how
that's your platform that's your show
every day so my understanding of that
has allowed me to to reach everyone and
and there's no way that you wouldn't
because that's that's what I truly feel
so this is a super important message for
entrepreneurs and one that I myself have
been working on over the past couple
years I have a media coach that I work
with named Jamie and her one word is
connect so I know she can strongly
relate to this video and I've been
working on being able to connect better
to my customers to my audience and it's
helped me have a lot more success in my
company you see as entrepreneurs is
something we can all get better at
because your story your ability to
connect with your customers is one of
the things that can help you stand out
against the big customers right why is
someone gonna buy from you over some
big-name brand that I've already worked
with before it's because of your story
because of your passion because of your
energy and a lot of entrepreneurs when
you know if I just go to your website
it's super boring its corporate its
commercial it's it's plain its average
and you want to be able to use your
story and your ability to connect to get
those new customers in the door if I
look at my own business you know I've
had success with my companies but I'm
still able to connect with the guy who's
just starting up and struggling to get
by because that was me I've had you know
this month are gonna have between 12 and
15 thousand new subscribers on the
channel but I'm still able to connect
with the person who's just starting up
or has a hundred subscribers and it's
trying to grow and that's not bragging
that's not to say how
how great I am I'm trying to share that
this is something that's led to my
success and has helped me and I know
that if you're better able to connect to
your customers and tell your story
you're much more likely to be able to
bring more business to your company so
tell your store on your website put your
picture up there create a video let me
feel your passion because if I can feel
that then I'm much more likely to buy
from you than somebody else
so my question of the day for you today
is what are you afraid of what's holding
you back from connecting truly from
really telling your story and putting
yourself out there I'm curious what's
holding you back leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event so today's messages
learn oh my god what is wrong there's
like something in man